[Música]
o
yo tuve la gran desgracia de que todo me
fuera fácil todo se me daba bastante
bien desde niña naturalmente sin mucho
esfuerzo no me costaba ni leer ni
aprender se me dan bien las matemáticas
pero también la geografía naturalmente
me podía integrar a los grupos hacía
amigos básicamente yo crecí pensando que
la vida era fácil que todo se podía que
todo lo podía
pre qué dimensión en qué tipo de niñas
yo era me subí a lo más alto de un
placard y me tiré pensando que podía
volar
pero lo hice dos veces dos veces me
tuvieron que coser el mentón y la
segunda vez que me tiré tenía diez años
todas mis hermanas que eran más pequeñas
que yo en edad me decían andrew baja te
vas a matar
cuando llegue a la etapa de la
universidad no era muy distinta esa niña
no me note en una carrera universitaria
me anoté en dos a la mañana cursaba
comunicación social y a la tarde iba a
ciencia política y los fines de semana
todos tenían energía y ganas de volverme
a mi ciudad en el interior de córdoba
y seguiré yo no me tomaré esfuerzo todo
eso pero me pareció fácil hasta el punto
que cuando yo me cruzaba con alguien a
quien le costaba aprobar aquí le costaba
hacer amigos al kiel y costeó el deporte
me costaba empatizar era como el otro a
jesse kelly costaba
por todo eso que les cuento
nunca sospeché que me iba a pasar lo que
les voy a contar ahora yo terminé de
cursar la universidad me quedaba el
sprint final esos últimos 100 metros los
últimos finales
me siento a estudiar
y no podía leer
sin ella las palabras entendía lo que
significaba no pero todas juntas no sí
en ningún sentido
las miraba y no lo entendía
mi cerebro que hasta entonces había sido
una olla que contenía todo y que lo
cocinaba de golpe era un colador que no
retenían nada
en esa época mi papá a partir de eso mi
apodo coco fundido decía que había
quemado el motor
y van tres meses tres meses de esta
situación
como si no fuera suficientemente
dramática la situación me gustó
agregarle un pequeño extra y decidí
subirme 25 kilos no cinco ni diez
veinticinco kilos
tenía tanto cachete que se me habían
tenía los ojos como achinados mi mamá me
decía que tenía un aire asiático y yo le
digo a tengo cara de chinita y dice no
bueno más tipo luchadores de sumo
y dan seis meses
donde estaba yo en el sofá como con el
coco fundido y la estética de una
luchadora de zumo donde estaba el otro
ese otro al que le costaba las cosas
recibiéndose trabajando avanzando en la
vida y ese es el problema cuando uno
crece creciendo que lo puede todo
no sabes cómo reconocerte débil no sabes
cómo pedir ayuda
fue como muy orgulloso para pedirla y
más orgulloso para aceptarla
tengo que reconocer que mi padre me
aguantaron bastante y luego sucedió lo
de manual tiraron la típica célebre
frase que tienen todos los padres
guardados para en algún momento decirnos
o estudias o trabajas
y ese día fue cuando oficialmente fui
declarado mi hogar una niña
bueno como estudiar no podía digo pues
busco trabajo
todos sabemos lo difícil que es buscar
trabajo con un título con buena
presencia de la autoestima intacta
imagínense lo quiere el desafío para mí
además yo les pregunto que pones en el
cb cuando no terminaste nada y encima
tiene cero experiencia que podés
me entero que hay una búsqueda para un
puesto de secretaria tomo el coraje y me
presenta y va a ser la primera
experiencia teniendo una entrevista
laboral
voy
tengo la hermosa suerte que el puesto
era para secretario del ceo de la
compañía y que el ceo el presidente el
dueño de la compañía había decidido el
hacer la entrevista a las candidatas que
podía salir mal
entro en la entrevista el impecable yo
estaba con los jeans negros lo único que
me entró para para ir a la entrevista él
en equilibrio mira esa gente que tiene
como un aura que emana éxito yo era un
montón de piezas sueltas rotas que pegué
como pude para llegar ahí estábamos los
dos que es lo primero que me dice
en esta empresa el valor más importante
es el compromiso pozos comprometidas
yo realmente no sé qué espera la gente
que uno lee koh antes de en ese momento
que iba a decir no vos sabes que tengo
muchos valores pero justo justo ese que
estás buscando no
y creo que está lejos de la
desesperación que tenía en salir de mi
situación y la vida obra milagrosamente
y misteriosamente y esto realmente es un
misterio porque ni siquiera es el que me
contrató sabe bien por qué eligió entre
todas las candidatas tomamos y arrancó
mi vida de secretaria
tres tareas sacar fotocopias servir café
y atender el teléfono desde las nueve de
la mañana hasta las seis de la tarde en
un bucle todos los días que estuviera
algo de mal esas tareas en sí mismas
pero recuerden que yo les conté que era
la niña que pensaba que podía volar o la
universitaria que se quería comer el
mundo me comí todo pero hasta ese
entonces jamás pero no el mundo digamos
y más que todo saben cuál era el
problema con esas tareas a mi me
recordaban todos los días
lo que no era lo que no fui lo que rompí
lo que había perdido
pero me mantenía me mantenían con cierto
entusiasmo y un día llegó ese punto de
inflexión
este punto que lo cambia todo y que no
tiene retorno mi jefe se acerca y me
dice andrea pudo vivir en el centro
verdad yo
centro de cerca este centro de salud
bueno puedes necesitar que dos una
gestión en mi nombre
primera de actividad de nuestra tarea
atribuido cómo funciona esto no de
expectativas ver su realidad la vida
yo con mi expectativa y cantando y la
realidad está por meterme en tres
cachetazos más de vuelta llega a las
seis de la tarde y me dice podéis ir a
la cocina a buscar una bolsa de la
cocina vamos a su auto trote y no
sospechaba nada sé cuando vi que abrió
el baúl y no la puerta dije
capaz de ver y oír abre el baúl qué es
lo que veo
un bidón de 3 litros
the peace
a lo que yo le digo yo viajo en el a6 en
el colectivo y él me dice no te
preocupes que está bien cerrado
mientras viajaba en hora pico con 40
grados a la sombra abrazada a un bidón
con 3 litros de pide mi jefe
soy lo que pensé
parece ser que soy comprometida
los primeros 10 minutos de colectivos
estaba un poco en shock en shock no se
trataba de está procesando una historia
en el fondo estaba decidiendo cómo me
iba a tomar en un momento sucedió fue
como un clic
como la magia algo que no estaba de
golpe está y saben que el tenis
entendí dos cosas muy importantes la
primera era que yo valía
yo tenía valor yo no necesitaba tener un
título universitario o una maestría en
la nasa un peso corporal óptimo para
tener valor yo tenía algo para dar a ese
jefe un espacio de trabajo una comunidad
y la otra cosa que entendí que mi
trabajo era digno que tampoco necesitaba
esperar tener ese puesto de gerente
super archi media de una corporación
para estar orgulloso de lo que yo hacía
yo le daba valor al trabajo yo definía
el trabajo no al revés
yo pensaba yo estoy para cosas grandes y
en ese momento entendí que yo hacía
grande ese puesto de trabajo
yo por luego me recibí hice una maestría
en españa volví a tener un peso
saludable finalmente tuve un puesto de
esos mega archi con gente a caroní si yo
tenía voluntarios que creían que tenía
valor ese espacio que yo lideraba y me
acompañaban
pero este entonces esta historia que les
cuento la historia del bidón era
simplemente una historia de reflexión
interna íntima no como una epifanía eso
que me permitió volver a ver el camino y
encaminar me
pero sucedió que yo quería estudiar eeuu
para san francisco a silicon valley a un
lugar de mucha elite y aplico me lance
uno de los requisitos que era la
entrevista la segunda entrevista en mi
vida
me presento con los mismos nervios sentí
hasta que me latía el cuero cabelludo
será el nivel de nervios
a veces la vida es irónica que es lo
primero que la entrevistadora me dice
y contar una historia en la cual podamos
ver reflejados tus valores
y yo la única historia que yo tenía en
la cabeza cuál era
entonces qué sucede arrancó arrancó en
ese sentido está desbarrancando bien
cuando ya no puede estrenar y ahí va con
mi historia del pie aparte imaginen que
se pertenece al mundo de las empresas
donde pintan las paredes de colores
donde tienen pus yo vengo del lugar
donde a veces se tiene que transportar
prix
yo les juro que me interesó le contaré
la historia la mujer tenía los ojos
mudos huevos yo no sé si es que estaba
horrorizada de lo que pasaba acá
sorprendido sentía pena
termine de contar la historia idiomas
a su silencio y lo siguiente que me
dicen sabe que es welcome to the
university
a mí me tomó ocho años terminar mi
licenciatura jamás hubiera tenido una
oportunidad que me aceptaran ahí si no
hubiera tenido una buena historia que
contar entonces esa historia que al
principio en una reflexión simplemente
se había convertido en una historia de
oportunidad que me abría una puerta
y yo la verdad no tenía más que pedirle
albion llamó a más y más me puede dar a
mi vida el bidón y miren qué curioso
este año me llaman para un programa que
se hace con fondos públicos que se llama
fish y cuál es el objetivo de este
programa que todos los jóvenes que no
están ni trabajando ni estudiando se
reincorporen al mercado laboral
que querían de mí
querían que yo le diera todo sos joven
está blando que por años pasan 40 mil o
más jóvenes por ahí les diseñar una
clase cero todo aquello que necesitarían
saber para hacer ese paso de línea al
fin
y sabes lo curioso de esto los que me
llaman no sabían que yo era una niña y
rehabilitada pero
también parece irónico que me llamarán y
le pregunté por qué a mí porque mis
conocimientos técnicos hay mucha otra
gente que los puede tener y me dijo
porque vos me transmitía entusiasmo y
compromiso con la vida y eso es lo que
quiero que los chicos selladas
vieron como la distancia en el tiempo y
la perspectiva en un poco de más de
madurez así que todas esas piezas
sueltas sino no lo encontrará donde
ponerlo empiezan a encajar yo no les
quiero apoyar el futuro yo la verdad que
los que me escuchan no sé en qué parte
de mi historia en sus propias vidas
están si les piden una tesis pendientes
y terminaron la universidad están en un
puesto de trabajo que aman o están
buscando trabajo pero yo lo que quiero
compartirles es que puedes fallar a
veces no depende del talento que tenga
de las ganas que le pongas de la fuerza
que le ponga a veces falla pero saben
qué
hay más de un camino para llegar a un
buen destino y finalmente finalmente los
valores se miden por la dignidad que uno
le pone a sus peores momentos
los valores no son
conceptos ideas en abstracto saberes los
valores pueden ser un millón de pie en
un colectivo en hora pico
los vinos los valores son historias
zonas eres
yo soy una persona comprometida y esta
historia que les conté es mi forma de
hacer
mi compromiso fue la única cosa que yo
tuve para poner en mi sede durante mucho
tiempo
la gente que realmente entiende dice que
las historias moldean a las personas
yo sinceramente pienso que es al revés
nosotros moldeamos a la historia
nosotros decidimos qué hacemos con eso
que nos pasa
y vivimos en un mundo que pareciera que
sólo tiene valor los logros económicos
los logros académico los logros
profesionales entonces saben hoy les
quiero pedir a cada uno de ustedes
quienes desde sus historias empiecen a
contar los valores de los que están
hechos porque saben que también son un
logro así que cuál es tu historia cuál
es tu vida dónde pisa mersey
[Aplausos]